Beauty? It's what it means to you. I
absolutely love being in control of what
people can and can't see. Me having that
power means I am liberated. Your women
are put into boxes, I personally as an artist don't like boxes. I want to reflect
my own creativity, draw outside the
lines. I think there's a shift in people
being unique. I'm a Ghanaian girl born and
raised in London, my face reflects that.
People prejudge me for the way I look
thinking that it was a choice. When I
lost my hair my femininity became
really important to me. I think it's
about doing it yourself and not trying
to conform to some standard of beauty.
I'm both masculine and feminine at the
same time. I don't think you have to
choose one. Femininity is just a word,
it's whatever you think it is, it's whatever
it means to you. My beauty, my rules.